the nominees for Best Actor this year
gave us performances that advanced the
movies never-ending quest to show us new
faces of the hero and expand the concept
of the leading man
here are the brilliant nominees for
performance by an actor in a leading
role Casey Affleck Manchester by to see
Andrew Garfield hacksaw edge Ryan
Gosling la la lune Viggo Mortensen
Captain Fantastic
send the Washington
ensign
and the Oscar goes to Casey Affleck
[Music]
this is the first Oscar and second
nomination for Casey Affleck
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nice uh thanks so much to me thank you
one of the first people who taught me
how to act was Denzel Washington and I
just met him tonight the first time
thank you and to all the other nominees
did great work I'm proud to be in your
company guys are very brave and I admire
what you do and I'm only here really
because of all that the talents and
goodwill so many people are impossible
to name but most of all Kenneth Larkin
who made this part and without this part
and without his writing I wouldn't be
here for sure and well he directed it
man I wish it something that's bigger
and warming equal to say but I've just
I'm really proud to be a part of this
community in general I look out at all
of you and I have this whole year and
just dumbfounded that I'm included and
it means a lot to me thank you also to
Matt Damon for creating this opportunity
to Mara box mom for so much and to
patrick consumer and so many people of
course my mother and my father for
mostly usually believing in me and doing
this and fanon love you you ain't heavy
thank you all very much